[Music]
and we're going to win four more years
in the white house
think of it this way donald trump is
trying to do something that nobody has
ever even attempted before in
modern history run for reelection
as an incumbent president who's never
been above 50 job approval
in the gallup poll never even been
attempted before what is this election
about
depends on who you ask we are in a
battle
for the soul of this nation if the left
gains power they will demolish the
suburbs
it's really about which candidate voters
trust
to bring the u.s out of three
massive moments of upheaval a health
care crisis
an economic collapse and a reckoning
around
racial equity that question what's the
election about is
really the baseline question for every
campaign and we forget that at our own
peril and i think in this case
in 2020 the election is basically a
referendum on donald j
trump i'm the only thing standing
between the american dream
and total anarchy madness and chaos and
that's what it is i'm representing you
i'm just here
to better understand how we got here we
have to rewind and go back to the start
of this year
before the coronavirus the equation was
much simpler
it was a question of whether the economy
was good enough to overcome the
misgivings and the doubts
and the uncertainty that people had
about whether they could stand
for more ears of donald trump he was
conducting a different kind of
presidency but he could say
i've given you an economic result that
you've got to be happy with
that was a very simple equation what i
heard from people even people who didn't
necessarily care for the president
they would say things like i don't love
the tweets i don't love some of the
style
but everyone in my family is employed my
401k is doing great
the u.s economy is now in its longest
economic expansion in history
it has been an unbelievable year for
stocks
article 1 is adopted
the trump campaign came into 2020
feeling pretty confident
the mueller report had come and gone the
president was impeached
but wasn't removed from office the trump
campaign had momentum coming
out of january and then on the way back
from his last international trip
in 2020 the president learned that the
situation with the coronavirus was
worsening
while trump is on air force one there's
a cdc press conference about
covid not whether it's going to come to
the country and spread but
how bad it's going to be trump stays up
the entire time
being concerned about what is being said
about coved he comes back he lands in
washington
and in fact the entire presidency the
entire race has changed
days later on february 29th south
carolina held its primary which marked a
historic moment
when democrats lined up behind joe biden
i would absolutely describe south
carolina as a turning point for joe
biden
congressman clyburn who is sort of a
king maker in south carolina politics
especially with african-american voters
ended up endorsing joe biden which kind
of sealed the deal for
joe biden i know
we know joe but most importantly
joe knows us there wasn't a clear front
runner at the beginning of the year on
the democratic side but there was a
sense that maybe bernie sanders time had
actually
arrived the party had moved to the left
progressives were ascendant
i think what changed was a sense of
almost panic in the democratic party we
can go with our heart and pick a bernie
sanders or an elizabeth warren that'll
make us happy as progressives
but maybe we should go with our head and
pick the guy who's going to be tougher
for donald trump to beat i am ending my
campaign
and endorsing joe biden for president
i'm delighted to endorse and support joe
biden for president
i've been doing this since 1980 one way
or another i've never seen a single
primary
change a presidential campaign the way
the south carolina
primary changed the 2020 race it did
that because joe biden went from being
foot in the grave to the dominant force
in the party in one day
the party establishment all lined up
behind joe biden i warned you i was
coming back and i'm back
i'm back almost universally and almost
immediately and that was a huge
statement
and it changed everything his basic
argument was that this is going to be
a campaign and an election about the
character of america
about not what my policies are about
whether i can bring people together
and stop being so divisive with one
another from the beginning of his
campaign
biden had made this theme a centerpiece
of his platform we
are in the battle for the soul of this
nation it seemed like almost a hokey
message at the beginning
it seems strangely resonant now
more specific aspects of biden's
platform include raising the minimum
wage
partial student loan forgiveness and an
emergency covert related paid leave plan
for at-risk workers
biden is also committed to tax policy
reforms which would raise corporate
taxes
and taxes on americans making more than
400 thousand dollars a year
in the days that followed biden won the
majority of super tuesday states handily
and picked up more endorsements i am
with great enthusiasm
going to endorse joe biden for president
of the united states
kamala harris was expected to endorse
joe biden
even though they had uh heated back and
forth uh
last june during a debate do you agree
today
that you were wrong to oppose busing in
america
then do you agree i did not oppose
busing in america what i opposed
is bussing ordered by the department of
education and when she endorsed him it
was interesting
because joe biden had corey booker on
one side and kamala harris on the other
side and said that he was going to be
the candidate who would be the bridge
the next generation of democrats
look i view myself as a bridge not as
anything else
there's an entire generation of leaders
you saw stand behind me
they are the future of this country as
joe biden secured his nomination
president trump delivered his first
public speech about the virus
my fellow americans this was to be the
president's first attempt to explain the
virus to the nation
and lay down some new travel
restrictions inside the white house
there was a lot of disagreement on
whether or not to even address the
nation over coronavirus
that fight happened all day to the point
where speech writing was happening
up until the last few minutes before the
cameras turned on in front of trump in
the oval office
and the speech itself is basically a
disaster
to keep new cases from entering our
shores
we will be suspending all travel from
europe to the united states for the next
30 days
his explanation of the europe travel ban
almost immediately had to be corrected
by aids people weren't clear who
exactly who it affected what countries
it affected did it affect goods
and then what it set off in the
subsequent days was a real
panic situation at european airports as
americans were you know
fleeing to try and come home god bless
you
and god bless america thank you so by
the end of this 10 minutes
there's all kinds of confusion in the
white house and outside of the white
house
stock futures almost immediately drop
and the next day we see the biggest
route in stocks
in 30 years the biggest drop we've seen
since that crash in 1987.
the president's order was similar to
those being used by other governments
around the world
to slow the spread of the virus after
reaching all-time highs in mid-february
the day after trump's speech in march
the dow slid around 2300 points
on rising fears of a global economic
slowdown more than a week later
the market bottomed as lawmakers
remained at odds over a stimulus package
but over the next six months the dow
recovered rapidly
to understand where trump is right now
you have to sort of consider where he
was at for
two plus years leading up to this point
he wants to run on the economy
the point at which it became clear the
coronavirus was the campaign story was
when
president trump decided to go out into
the white house press briefing room
every day at five o'clock or thereabout
so that told you he realized this had
become the story
around this time trump began to promote
coronavirus policies
contrary to those being pushed by
healthcare professionals
elected officials across the country
were struggling to find a balance
between protecting public health and
limiting damage to the economy
on march 23rd the president said that
the economy
needed to reopen soon we cannot let the
cure be worse than the problem itself
we're not going to let
the cure be worse than the problem what
frustrated people inside the white house
was that they knew that this was a
nationwide emergency
and that people were tuning in to get
moment-by-moment information
amid a crisis and what they were seeing
in a lot of cases was trump
sparring with reporters on ancillary
issues
you're so disgraceful it's so
disgraceful in early april
the cdc issued its first recommendation
that americans should wear
masks in public this is voluntary
i don't think i'm going to be doing it
it was a sign a signal
from the president and he's really good
at signaling people
in his base out there that he wasn't
going to go along with this because
masks were seen as a sign that we needed
to stay hunkered down
and it was the symbolism of the mask
that was really important
from that point on because people who
were wearing masks were essentially
saying
i think the country needs to stay
hunkered down and maybe even shut down
one of those was joe biden
who early on took a strong position in
support of wearing masks
when you go in in public going forward
will you be wearing a mask
yes look i think it's important to
follow the science
listen to the experts do what they tell
you
people who weren't marrying masks were
saying i'm with president trump
we need to get out of the foxhole and
start living again in mid-april
public anger about mass regulations and
lockdown measures
led to protests at the michigan state
capitol in lansing
protests in michigan really signaled the
start of sort of the culture wars
around the virus and what we saw
throughout the country
were very different feelings on how
governments should be treating this
whether or not businesses and states
should be shutting down
but it also showed a real variance of
opinion
on whether you're trusting your elected
officials whether you're trusting the
guidance of healthcare professionals
this is a classic example where the
picture is worth
a thousand ten thousand a million words
i don't think most of us
realized how it was so quickly going to
snowball into these huge protests all
across
the country i would talk to a lot of
white folks in philadelphia who would
say like five years ago they would have
never said black lives matter and here
they are
black lives matter t-shirt and a poster
and have
their third night on the street um and
then for a lot of the black folks i
talked to
um you know watching that clip of floyd
was just heartbreaking and and a lot of
folks that had enough
and they could think of nothing else
they could do except take to the streets
to
voice that frustration in the days
following george floyd's death
president trump tweeted a message many
critics felt was highly divisive
with the tweet looting and shooting the
president
made clear what his campaign message was
going to be at a time
when a lot of democrats and republicans
were
calling for a president to be less
divisive
and to talk about race in a more
sort of healing way he was clearly
building up this message of
law and order where he was going to
accuse democrats
of instigating chaos in liberal-leaning
cities
the tweet was later flagged by twitter
for violating the company's rules about
glorifying violence
after the outcry trump said he was not
aware of the phrase's origin
people forget about this in 2016 and
much less dire
circumstances he says in his acceptance
speech at the republican convention
i'm going to be the law and order
candidate in this campaign
an attack on law enforcement
is an attack on all americans
after a week of unrest across the
country in late may
president trump visited saint john's
church across the street from the white
house
the president's visit led to peaceful
protesters being forcibly removed from
the area
a couple days before news had broken
that trump had been taken to a safe
bunker inside the white house
while protests erupted around the white
house complex trump is very concerned
about the image this portrays and
and decides almost at the last minute to
have law enforcement
clear protesters from the park in front
of the white house so that he and his
aides can walk over to a church
and he can hold up a bible in triumph
he wanted to show that he could come out
that he was surveying the damage that he
was strong
but he also very much wanted to signal
to the christian right who remain a key
part of his political base
but he is with them and he supports them
over the summer
protests swept across the country
statues were torn down and videos of
violent
clashes between protesters and police
were shared widely on social media
although largely peaceful some of these
protests
descended into writing and looting on
june 7th
a wall street journal nbc news poll
found that 80 percent of the country
felt that the nation was spiraling out
of control i think that poll did capture
what people were
feeling the news is filled every day
with reports about
death tolls rising cases rising
people are really really worried i can
think of two
times when this happened during a
presidential election year previously
1968 vietnam war racial discord in the
streets
civic unrest at the democratic
convention a kind of a feeling the
wheels are falling off the cart
in 1980 you have stagflation
you have a feeling that the energy
crisis is out of control people are in
gas lines
iranian students take uh hostages at the
american embassy in tehran
again a feeling the wheels are coming
off the cart so how does it work this
time
you would think it's not good news for
the incumbent but it's also been good
news for the law and order candidate in
the past
in late june trump attempted to take his
campaign back on the road to tulsa
the campaign schedules a rally in tulsa
oklahoma
they're looking for a location with low
cases of virus they think they can do it
safely
and they schedule it for juneteenth
which is of course the celebration of
emancipation of slaves in america
and activists there were concerned that
him being there amid all this unrest
and in tulsa specifically which has such
a
dark history tulsa was the site of one
of the worst race riots in u.s history
after critics accused the president of
insensitivity the rally was rescheduled
for june 20th
but on the day of the event things
didn't go as planned
the campaign started estimating that
hundreds of thousands of people were
going to descend upon tulsa for this
rally
in reality only about 6 000 people show
up and it's the first rally
in five years that is half empty for
trump until this point both candidates
had relied on virtual events to get
their message out
joe biden is really a retail politician
he
loves to be in front of people and he
loves to get close to them and have
personal conversations and give hugs and
this campaign has not played to those
strengths
for a lot of the summer joe biden was
not terribly visible
the the trump joke was that he was
hiding in his basement
but really he was doing interviews and
tv appearances
and zoom appearances the reason i'm so
optimistic is because of your generation
600 000 brave postal workers deserve our
full support
the biden campaign's argument was number
one we're listening to the scientists
and they say it's not safe to do these
things
and number two they felt like they just
needed to stay out of trump's way
and let him make his own mess on august
11th
bine announced kamala harris as his
running mate your next vice president
united states kamala harris this
fulfilled a promise
he made back in march i commit that i
will in fact appoint a
i'll pick a woman to be vice president
there was a lot of
pressure on joe biden to pick a black
woman
because of the widespread support he had
gained from
black people during the primary and
saying that black people had saved his
campaign
she was the obvious choice a woman of
color who had
done respectably well as a candidate
herself and who had
a significant base in california a lot
of money
support the obvious and in some ways the
safest
choice after being postponed for a month
because of coronavirus concerns
the dnc kicked off in august but the
four-day event was significantly
downsized
most of the speakers participated
virtually or pre-taped their comments
even the candidate didn't travel to the
host city milwaukee
to accept his nomination usually there
are thousands and thousands of people
packed into a stadium or an arena for a
few days
we basically saw none of that this year
the message that democrats and joe biden
were trying to get across
was that joe biden is portraying him as
a healer
showing that he's someone who has been
through grief and tragedy and can bring
people together
at the convention the democrats
definitely want to put the focus on the
pandemic and
the recession they really try to draw a
connection between
the president's handling of the virus
and
how that relates to not only the economy
but also on how it affects their
livelihood and trying to speak to the
frustrations people feel with the
lockdowns we'll have a national mandate
to wear a mask
not as a burden but as a patriotic duty
to protect one another
a week later republicans presented a
much different message
at their convention biden is a trojan
horse for socialism
in contrast with the dnc some rnc events
were held in person
and in many cases attendees didn't wear
masks or social distance
no one will be safe in biden's america
in the days that followed
biden pushed back on trump's accusations
ask yourself
do i look like a radical socialist with
a soft spot for rioters
really a month later three themes that
have dominated the campaign
the coronavirus the economic fallout and
civil unrest
all came to a head as the two candidates
finally met face to face
although neither candidate wore masks
they did socially distance from one
another
on the manifesto we call it what matters
is you socialize medicine
look hey are you still not gonna listen
to them the fact that what americans saw
on tuesday night was less a debate and
more a verbal brawl a kind of a verbal
food fight
in which there was a lot of insulting
and they were interrupting in which most
of the rules of decorum that have marked
presidential debates in the past
simply went out the window when needed i
wear a mask
okay let me ask i don't have i don't
wear mess like him every time you see
him he's got a mask he could be speaking
200 feet away from it he shows up with
the biggest mask i've ever seen
days after the debate on october 2nd
president trump tweeted that he had
tested positive for the virus
that evening he headed to walter reed
medical center i'm going to walter reed
hospital
i think i'm doing very well the
president has since been released but it
remains uncertain if he will debate joe
biden
in the weeks to come